Hello, there, the Internet.
I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
Usually, we get a lot of suggestions
from you, the audience
and we appreciate them.
And we often shoot them.
And we've done quite a lot.
Nobody suggested this one. I've never-
It's gargling.
I wrote this down about five years ago
because I thought it
might look interesting.
And honestly I have no idea
if it will look interesting
but I really want to see
if we can see some rippling in your uvula.
Everything is always soft
stuff in there, isn't it?
So I reckon it should
be right good action.
It'll either be really boring
or fascinatingly gross.
Let's find out.
[Gav] Taking advantage of that winter sun.
Getting it directly into my gob.
Think about this.
The light
traveled for eight minutes across space,
went into your mouth,
and hit your uvula.
Bounced back into the lens.
Into the lens.
Went onto the Internet.
Millions of people saw it.
Oh, gross.
It goes into a really fine point.
Lookit, it's like ... Oh.
It's hitting itself.
It looks like a second tongue,
going ape.
It looks like that little alien,
you know that alien with the second mouth?
It looks like that.
[Gav] The lighting in in this back garden
is atrocious.
Yeah.
All right. We'll try with
water this time, shall we?
Yeah. As you can see,
I've got my receptacle here.
Yeah.
I'll just...
I don't actually have any
cups here today.
Sounds good.
Yeah.
Daniel is now
figuring out the optimal
amount of -
of gargle fluid.
There we go.
[Gav] All right.
Who knows what that looked like?
Oh, God.
Oh, it's getting slapped around in there.
The water's like...
Oh, why is that so much more disgusting
than I thought it would be?
It's going left and right.
You're getting water all over the place.
It's like .
It's thrashing like a whale.
It's being flipped around by the water.
Look at that.
Oh, man.
It's like a shark,
attacking a bunch of fish.
Ohhh.
It's so amazing for some reason.
Why is this so mesmerizing?
That was gross.
Good grief.
Yeah, why were we not
wearing lab coats for that?
I mean-
Well, because we didn't
really learn anything
or prove anything.
We didn't really do anything.
All I did was gargle and
I was wearing a lab coat.
Well I'm sure someone could figure out
the frequency of your uvula
when it was thrashing around like a shark.
We've benefited society in this.
There we go.
Well, hopefully you've
recovered from that.
We've almost recovered.
Just remember, every time
you brush your teeth and gargle,
that is happening in your mouth.
Okay, so think about that next time
you're doing it.
I don't want to.
No?
No, I don't want to think about it.
It's pretty mean.
And you don't have a very big uvula.
Ohhh.
I've seen mine's bigger.
We should do uvula auditions.
Who's got a big uvula?
If you've got a massive uvula ...
I once heard that uvula was Latin
for "little grape".
If that was a grape,
I think I wouldn't want to eat it.
People like uvulas.
All right, well feel free
to follow us on Twitter
subscribe to the channel
if you love the mo.
And you can buy a shirt
and a poster, also.
Let's do this.
See you in the next video.
Let's do this?
Video's over.
Let's do this.
Did you know I'm in a movie?
Well, I am, and it's called Lazer Team,
and there are still tickets available
to the very first screenings
on the 27th and the 28th of January
in the US, Canada, UK,
Australia, even New Zealand,
that's well far away.
So, if you fancy seeing a movie,
what I am in,
click the link
and get yourself a ticket.